it turns out plants have friends they
can talk to kind of sort of molecular
biologists at Japan's saitam University
constructed a pump that shows in real
time how damaged and distressed plants
worn other unharmed plants near them of
approaching danger after letting loose
some caterpillars on cut leaves from
tomato plants and weeds the researchers
were able to view how the unheard plants
around them received the warning signals
quickly and which cells were first to
react the leaves of the plants on the
receiving end glowe when sensing an
increase in calcium ions something our
cells also use to communicate with each
other this is the latest science news
this is mind blown we've just used human
fetal brain tissue to grow mini brains
they grew to about the size of a single
grain of rice and had self-organizing
cells that formed into multiple 3D
structures researchers were also able to
grow tumors on the mini brains and test
responses to current cancer drugs this
marks the first time scientists were
able to develop these 3D organoids from
the human brain previous developments
were possible from stem cells from most
other human organs stem cells must be
given a platform to grow on whereas
brain tissue can make its own author of
the study Delilah Hendrix says these new
fetal tissue derived organoids can offer
novel insights into what shapes the
different regions of the brain and what
creates cellular diversity no word yet
on growing Mother Brain the world's
first working graphine based
semiconductor has arrived scientists
chemically bonded silicon carbide to a
particular crystal structure of carbon
forming epitaxial graphine making
transistors from this compound means
operating at 10 times the speed of
traditional silicon based transistors
used in chips currently meaning it can
work in terahertz frequencies and allows
for the electrons inside to move with
much less impediment while rapid
advancements in Computing have begun to
is slow because of the limitations in
traditional silicon based semiconductors
graphine uses a single layer of carbon
atoms in a tight hexagonal lattice
making it a better conductor and its
mechanical wavelike qualities allow it
to be used by devices at low
temperatures let's talk about the color
of Uranus and Neptune New Image
processing shows Neptune as seen by The
Naked human eye a pale bluish green
color similar to Uranus in the 1980s
NASA's Voyager 2 took photos of the
outer planets and what a sent back
showed Neptune as a much darker Deeper
Shade of blue incredibly different than
Uranus even though both planets share
similar qualities such as mass chemical
makeup and size now University of Oxford
researchers reprocessed those photos to
show a vastly different Neptune a hazy
pale bluish green to explain the
differences the original Voyager 2 took
photos at an enhanced contrast ratio to
show atmosphere details otherwise
hard to see and the color balancing made
the planet appear a deep blue then if
you're feeling hostile just sniff a
woman's tears a study at a vicman
Institute of Science in Israel has found
that smelling a woman's tears diminish
the feeling of aggression in men which
led to less aggressive behaviors this
process in mice is known as social chemo
signaling and was less understood in
humans until now when tested on men
during an aggression evoking game and
then retested in an MRI scanner
revengeful and aggressive behaviors
dropped by over 40% and the prefrontal
cortex and anterior insula the two
aggression regulated brain areas were
not active in the tear sniffing men as
opposed to the men who only smelled
saline solution importantly this Alters
the preconception that emotional tears
are solely human reindeer chew food in
their sleep researchers at the Norwegian
Institute of bioeconomy research
attached metal electrodes to four
captive reindeer and monitored them
using an electroencephalograph for the
next several days the EEG found through
brain waves that the reindeer were in a
light state of sleep while ruminating
and this is thought to be a sort of
animal recharging they also found that
the longer the animals ruminated the
less they needed any extra rest later on
this is especially helpful in these
summer months when the reindeers spend
their time eating in preparation for the
longer winter months when food is scarce
in Rosie the robot from the Jetson's
news here's your real robot housekeeper
mobile Aloha a wholebody lowcost
teleoperation system is able to clean
cook and open and close cabinets this
system uses a mobile base and whole body
interface coupled with supervised
Behavior cloning and co-training to
learn mobile manipulation tasks with a
success rate of up to 90% all of this
results in the mobile Aloha being able
to autonomous do more complicated tasks
like putting away heavy cookware and
rinsing out a pan in the sink it has two
wrist cameras a top camera and can even
give high fives at a $32,000 budget
including onboard power and open- Source
software and Hardware the team hopes to
reduce the overall footprint of Aloha
and give the two robotic arms more
movement freedom to reach lower surfaces
it's time for liquid magnet propellers
at the University of electr
commmunications in Japan Jun shinaki and
colleagues created a prototype for a new
aquatic propeller made from ferrofluid
it consists of magnetic iron oxide
nanoparticles suspended in oil they're
prototypes controlled with magnets that
rapidly switch on and off this concept
would be much safer to Aquatic Wildlife
eliminating the need for heavy metal
propeller blades that often injure or
kill anything that comes in contact with
them but obviously we are a long ways
away from the fluid fluid Locomotion of
these robots scaling up to a fishing
boat that battles jaws and now for Star
Wars the arcade game in 1983 mind blow
is a patreon supported program so join
us thanks bye for the the use the force
coming too fast way way my Shields are
gone all right St going
in